well I am pretty sure you shouldn't have
a weapon at work literally everything is
a weapon son that folder in my hands is
far deadlier than this bow and yours oh
that's you probably true
so Leslie and I just finished putting
together our will and she wants you to
be the witness you mind signing it
that's your will you need that many
pages to say give my stuff to my wife
it's a complicated legal document
doesn't have to be I've had the same
will since I was eight years old upon my
death all of my belongings shall
transfer to the man or animal who has
killed me we're in these weird symbols
the man who kills me will know okay you
should really have a will that's more
than one sentence long you have a wife
and kids now I could introduce you to
our lawyer the three most useless jobs
in the world are in order
lawyer congressman and dr. Paz Ron that
document is nothing it's not even
notarized you know if you die and you
don't have a real will most of what you
own will go to the government where's
this lawyer you speak of mr. Swanson
let's begin by filling out this form
listing your assets and liabilities nice
try
I'm not telling you how much money I
have where it's hidden or which precious
metals and/or gemstones it may or may
not take the form of if you don't give
me the information I need there's
nothing I can do
I'm come on Trevor where there's a will
there's a way
I'm gonna say this one last time wet
check the accountant crap at the door
yes sir I will
unintentional I don't even need an exact
number just ballpark it that's all I
need to get started or I'm sure the
state government would love to use your
money to hire more bureaucrats maybe
build a library fine a ballpark figure
thank you good
holy is this a joke another word for
jokes is lies I do not lie therefore I
do not joke mr. Swanson in a state of
this size means that your children would
never have to work a day in their lives
this is going to take some time trusts
need to be drawn tax shelters that's
enough I do not need some drawn-out
legal expedition to tell me what I knew
when I was eight here's my original will
do whatever lawyer nonsense you have to
to make it official and I will sign a
good day wait what are all these symbols
I was right not to be threatened by you
We Need to Talk
that has never been true I think I know
what's happening
thinking about how to divide up your
possessions for when you die it's tough
confronting your own mortality and I
think it's got you spinning a little bit
all right Wow I had not considered that
yes I think that maybe you were onto
something
yeah just know that it's perfectly
healthy to be thinking about oh you're
joking yes son I am first joke ever
don't care for it death does not scare
me what I am worried about is spoiling
my children I don't want them to be the
kind of people who never work live off
their trust funds who buy their wooden
furniture
I will leave my children $50 a piece for
the cab home from my funeral and a steak
dinner end of discussion
okay I mean look it doesn't matter how
much money you leave your kids what
matters is that you teach them the right
values but if something horrible happens
and you want your kids to be left alone
with no safety net just so they can
learn some kind of weird lesson then by
all means leave your fortune to the wild
boar who Gore's you to death and never
lose to a boar Benjamin after thinking
about what you said I've decided to
leave each of my children 5% of my
fortune Wow
five whole percent so I guess you are
gonna teach them a lesson
oh my god that's five percent that is a
lot of money wait is this a joke
it is not a joke not that an accountant
wouldn't know the difference
also if something should happen to Diana
and me we decided that the kids should
go to the most important people in our
lives
I'm I'm incredibly flattered
ralphe Piotrowski and his wife Helen
he's the maitre d at Mulligan's
Steakhouse and he knows me better than
anyone however if they are not able to
do it which seems likely is they're in
their 90's you and Leslie are choice
number two
you